[Music]
so this is my first time at the PI data
conference and I want to thank the
organizers for inviting me so I come
from I work for the Philadelphia 76ers
and I'll show you how do we use data to
change the game of basketball so let's
just get started so imagine you're at a
basketball game and you're sitting there
with your friend watching a game and
you're not looking at the scoreboard so
you're just watching a game and you
don't know what the score is maybe in a
half time you are trying to guess what
is the actual score of the game would
you think you would be confident
guessing the score who thinks they could
guess it okay so the points in
basketball and the score is the most
important and most elemental data point
that happens in a basketball game so if
we cannot track the score by not
actually writing it down how can we
track anything else that happens in a
game so basketball is a game where you
have five players on each team and a lot
of actions happen simultaneously and
it's hard to keep track of all of them
and everything that happens there so
let's say you're a coach and you want to
adjust your strategy based on how the
game is going up down until you know a
halftime so if you don't have a data how
will you be able to adjust it
objectively you will you will be very
biased on on things you remember that
happen in game and and base your
adjustments on that so for example let's
say a player scores a point out of a
pick-and-roll action and we had to
evaluate if this if this point is
because the player was really good and
he did something amazing is this point
because the defense was bad and
the offense was maybe just average is
the point maybe because his teammate did
something else on the other side of the
court that maybe we were not even paying
attention to so all these things will
will change how we evaluate the game how
we evaluate the players and they're very
hard to keep track of and that's why we
started adding more data to the
basketball game so we started with the
scoreboard and then I'll take you to the
30 evolution of how we added more data
into tracking basketball games but
before that I will give you a little bit
of background or where this analytics in
sport really started so it started with
baseball and the reason for that is
because baseball is a more static game
and there was a lot of data there was
already tracked with it with in baseball
with basic box scores and you don't lose
as much information from a box score as
much as you do in a basketball game
which we'll get to you'll get to there
later so these are some of the first
stages of development of the analytics
in baseball so bill James was the one of
the pioneers in baseball analytics and
with that sports analytics in general so
he developed new metrics to evaluate
baseball players so this started in
nineteen in 1970s later on Billy Beane
was the GM of the Oakland A's he started
actually implementing these principles
in the way he was building a team so in
the way he was bringing players to his
team and evaluating Cal players before
him
so that was there was an early mm so you
can see there was a lot of time from
when Bill James started publishing these
research articles until it was actually
applied to evaluate players in a team so
it took it took 20 years to do that and
then you've probably seen a movie
Moneyball so there was a book a book was
published
it's about Billy Beane and how he
actually implemented these research
metrics to build the Oakland A's team
and then in 2011 the movie version was
published and that's when it became very
popular it became well-known that these
things are actually being done in in in
sports so just to show you an example
this is what old baseball tracking
looked like so a lot of people would go
to the games and they would track their
own stats and this is the reason why
early on baseball had a lot more data
than the other sports and and again it's
a study game so you know a pitcher
throws the ball there are 11 innings and
things are very sequential sequential so
some of the strategies started to change
in in baseball so one of the examples is
this one so you can see that there's a
there's a picture in the middle and he's
tearing the ball to the batter when the
lower edge of the diamond and all of
these players that are on the right side
are defenders so their job is to catch
the ball once the batter hits it because
they had all this data and they knew
about this batter where he normally hits
the ball they position all the defenders
in that part of the field you can see
the left part is pretty empty there's
only one defender on that side so this
was they were able to do this thanks to
collecting more data in the baseball
so this was this has been happening in
the last 15-20 years however in
basketball everything started a little
later and the first person who did
something more advanced I will play a
video because it's Ohio's case Institute
of Technology one only six out of 16
games last year so this season Don Knuth
student mathematician used an electronic
computer to evaluate each player's
performance here's how he did it
during scrimmage Knuth builds a
performance record of each player noting
everything from baskets to fumbles this
data is put on punched cards and fed to
an IBM computer capable of making fifty
thousand calculations a minute coach
Phil Heim checks the computer's rating
of each player's performance at an
actual game he refers to the computers
findings as his strategy changes does
the system work coach I'm think so
his team won 11 out of 14 games so far
this year so was computer scientist who
developed the system while he was
studying so this was 1958 so a very long
time ago but he hasn't done much in or
probably anything in in sports analytics
since then he moved on and did some more
amazing things in the field of computer
science he wrote the book the art of
computer programming which was one of
the first book in computer algorithms
and studying algorithms he's also
creator of tech the typesetting system
they all use late
and yeah he was one of the creators so
so this is 1958 and not much data was
collected in that time so in so this is
a box score from an NBA game in 1962 so
you can see the data that's collected
it's it's pretty basic it's the shots
taken shooting percentages free throws
rebounds and not even not even
specifying if it's offensive of
defensive rebounds it was just total
rebounds number of the assists you can
see those empty fields like steals
blocks turnovers they were not even
tracked at that time so you can notice
this specific game is when will
Chamberlain scored 100 points this is a
March 2nd 1962 so at that time they were
still collecting only you know about 20
to 30 euros of data per game it was very
basic very minimal processing was
required to analyze this data but there
is no context provided you don't know if
certain player plays with other players
you don't know against which players he
was playing at a time and it's also
purely outcome based so you only know
the things that happen and things that
are that they decided to count at the
time so it was it was very basic and and
this was four years after Donald Knuth
was helping his college team win more
games so so there was 62 and then the
added the assists the turnovers and and
and others and blocks but there was all
the data they collected just the box
score until 1996 season when they
started writing down the play-by-play
which is basically a sequential list of
events that happen in the game but again
it's all the events
that are that they decided to count so
you again have points you have assists
you have fouls rebounds so again very
very comfortable things but but it gives
you a little more context you know when
certain things happen so it preserves
the temporal part of the data and you
know which players were in accord
together when certain actions happened
so it gives you a little bit more
context to the data it it required a
little bit more processing than than
just reading the box score but again
very basic not not much machine learning
so it gives you so we went from twenty
to thirty rows of data to about three
hundred to four hundred per game so one
thing that they started tracking with
play-by-play was locations of shots so
included play you would see the location
where the shot was taken so this was
like the first spatial data that there
was collected was locations of shots
whether they made immersed and who took
second shot so they looked something
like this
so we have play-by-play and and shot
locations and once we have this some
people realized that they could evaluate
players a little better than it's been
done so far soft until the point people
would look at total points per game
total rebounds per game for a player for
a team and evaluate them based on that
but then they realized players who have
a lot of rebounds I also the players who
play on bad teams because they're their
team's their team misses a lot of shots
so they have more opportunities to get
the rebound so some of the people that
started looking at these advanced stats
that that recall at a time which is
really just instead of looking at totals
they were looking at percentages so
instead of looking at total rebounds in
a game they look at percentage of
rebounds collected by a player while he
was on the court
out of the total miss shots so they gave
you gave it gives it a little more
specificity unlike the rebounds the
total rebounds depend on how many shots
are taken how many shots are missed but
if you if you want to just evaluate
rebounding this was a way to do that so
these are some of the names of the
people who started developing these
advanced metrics and and started started
developing research in in basketball
statistics so but there was still it was
still pretty basic I can see it's you
know the advanced stats was was looking
at percentage instead of totals and then
in early early 2000s a company named
sport view decided to track the players
in the game so they position the cameras
in the arena's which would track all the
players and everything that happens
during a game so so sports view company
was bought by stats in 2008 and I
decided to just focus on basketball and
provide the tracking data to the NBA
team so they did a first demo in 2009
during the finals in Orlando and the
following year five teams actually
bought the system so they had to install
the cameras and I need to pay for the
service of receiving this data so at the
time it was only five teams and and they
the cameras were only in five arenas so
these teams could only get their own
data they could so it so the data they
had was really biased on how they play
because it was only their games and and
they had a data of the opponents as well
but it was in their games and then in
2013 NBA signed a contract with this
company to provide the data to all of
the teams so since then
every arena has the cameras and they
collected data for every team and and
everything gets the data from the
opponents and from every single game in
the NBA so what is this this data really
it's a it's a spatial and temporal data
it's a it gives us locations of players
on the court in 25 frames per second so
we get the locations of the player in in
X&Y coordinate and we get XY and z
coordinates for the basketball so so we
get so we go from 400 years of data to
about million throws the data per game
so a lot more processing is required and
and machine learning techniques are
required to actually analyze this data
so additionally to just the coordinates
of the players we also have the markings
on when certain events happen so we have
all the dribbles we have all the pick
and rolls we have the rebounds all the
shots and then they're marked in terms
of which players took it when did he
take it we can also see who was
defending him at the time and so we have
a lot more richer data and rich context
that that events happen and we not only
know who was who was on the court at the
same time we display and who was the
opponent at a time we also know how this
action happened
and what happened on the other side of
the court that did the action on the
side matter or not we can we can also
try to evaluate those things now so when
this started on started early on some
things took a while to to adjust to to
actually start using this data one of
the teams that were among the first ones
who were using this data extensively in
developing complex models on it were
deterrent Raptors so this article is
published by exact low and and it really
built the light to to what has been what
was going on and what would be what
proteins doing with this data so this is
one of the examples of
the model they had so you can see the
players are the blue and white circles
and a little little transparent circles
I call ghost defenders so so to develop
the model that would evaluate where what
is the best strategy for each defender
at each moment and where who should he
be to help his defense the most so this
was really early on and this was really
advanced the article was published in
2013 so but it didn't really go that
smoothly like teams didn't really adjust
the TV personal didn't comment on it in
a positive way they would say things
that it doesn't work it's just a bunch
of nerds who want to influence the
basketball games so he took a lot of
time to for people to start accepting
this because the the coaches and the TV
analysts that we used to use in the
Gutfeld to evaluate players to just talk
about the game and make strategy
adjustments so so not everybody accepted
is really early on one of the teams that
was very receptive
well the Houston Rockets so this is what
their shot chart looks like so you can
you can see that there's a lot of shots
that are taken from the tape online and
around the basket but not much in
between so if you see in this chart are
the Houston Rockets took these the
numbers percent represent the
percentages of shots in that region so
they took only 13% of shots between away
from the basket and three-point line so
around this this area this whole area
and the NBA average was this last year
was 27% you can see it's been going down
in in recent years so it's it's not
really like it's not really an advanced
analytics to to realize that you know 3
is worth more than 2 but
the problem was that players will make
3-point shots about 35% on average and
they'll make a two-point shot that it's
pretty far from the basket at about 42%
and and it seems like they're making
them more offering sorry so why not take
them more but in reality the extra
points you get from the 3-point shot
even if you don't make it as often is
actually beneficial and I don't think
they didn't really need the player
checking cameras to realize this so it
was just a way of starting to accept the
analytics and and so to accept new the
changes in the game you can tell you can
tell a coach hey you should take more
3-point shots unless those long
two-point shots but we couldn't see how
we can get those shots and in what
situations we could go get them until we
had all these data so we can objectively
say hey this is a situation where you
could take the take one shot instead of
this two-point shot so the game start is
starting to really change this is one of
the most popular adjustments that the
game has made in recent years so it's
not just at the teams I adjust and also
players are excited to change the way
they play so this was a one of the NBA
players in 2014 his shots were looked
something like this
so he took a lot of shots here in this
long - area and a lot around the rim and
some here so you can you can guess this
player was like a center he played
around the basket a lot and last year
this is the same player four years later
he's shot rights changed significantly
so he started taking a lot more
three-point shots even even like a few
steps behind at a four in line and he
really only takes the pigment shots and
shots around the basket now so so you
can see the game is really really
changing so baby because the the offense
has changed
defense we're also going to have to
change one of the examples that we can
get from the data that we have now so in
the box score the only record assists
and an assist is when you pass it balls
to somebody who makes the shot but there
are a lot more things that are more
responsible for making a shot than the
actual pass like for example a screen
assist is when a player makes the screen
to free up his teammate like this to
free up his teammate and give him a
wide-open layup so so we couldn't track
this before like we had no information
about these kind of events
without having the player tracking data
and as I said as the offenses change in
the defense is also going to change as
well so this is one of the papers that
was presented at analytics conference in
at MIT so they developed a system where
you you see here the locations of the
players and from that you can infer who
is defending which player so in this
example it may look pretty obvious but
if the players are more closer together
it will become a lot more difficult so
if we know which player is defending
which player it gives us a lot more
defensive information for readers a lot
there are a lot of things on the
defensive end that are still very
difficult to evaluate even with this
player tracking data but we're working
on the models to evaluate that for
example there are certain things that
are depending on the defensive scheme
that the coach is choosing there are
certain interactions between players
that are still really difficult to
evaluate which player is really really
responsible for a good or a bad defense
so just another example this is not
defensive metric this is just grouping
different actions on the court so we can
we can find similar positions that
happen in in the game of basketball and
group them so for example if a player if
a coach holds a play and he wants to
know how successful this play is and and
whether he should call this play more
often or whether he should try something
different
so we can group certain certain actions
together and find one when did the coach
Paul display in in every game and we can
also find other teams that that use the
similar kind of play in their game and
we can evaluate how successful this
display against certain defenders may be
against certain teams and and which
players are worse more successful using
this kind of play compared to maybe some
other players so we have all we have we
have a lot more data now that we can
evaluate we can use to evaluate teams
and vascular players so so we can use it
to form a strategy for the game we can
use it to perform a lineup that we
should play in a game we can see certain
players play well against certain
opponents so maybe you will try to match
the lineup of the players against the
opponents that play well against also
when we are signing a player when we are
looking to trade a player and trade for
a different player we can use all this
data to evaluate the players better then
than we could before but there's still
there's still some things that are
missing from the data and it's primarily
the things that don't happen we don't
know if a player was looking a certain
direction and decided to not do certain
event but certain action and do
something else so so there's still a lot
a lot more work than that we can do but
I would say we've come a long way in
last five years really since we had
this data and the game is is really
adapting to it and the game is really
changing with all this new data so um a
little early but I'm happy to take any
questions you have and thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
[Applause]
why no I would never I wonder I am do
you run models in game to make
adjustments I don't know if you tell the
coaches something about you fine
and what kind of models you run if you
do it so so Jun the game if we have all
this data previous to this game we do in
the game you only have like small amount
of data added to the old data that we
already have so it would probably not
change how we think about the game based
on that that small amount of data you
probably wouldn't want to react to to a
small sample size that happens during a
game there are certain adjustments that
we can make just by just by seeing
things that happen seeing which player
was was better by looking at it really
the box score and play-by-play data
during the games but the player tracking
data we don't use it during the games we
actually don't get the game data until
maybe an hour later hour after the game
ends so it takes a bit of time to
process it and to actually make
decisions on it thanks hi thank you for
your representation I have somewhat
related question are there plans for
adding some extra data some extra
sensors maybe something you know it's a
little difficult due to the rules in the
NBA we can't really have sensors and
players during the game so so we can't
really get the data from sensors what
you could do is look at the video and
maybe analyze it a little more like we
could use like pose data and then see
the players arms location maybe and
their feet location and how they're
positioned in the defense so right now
we only have coordinates x and y we
don't know which direction player is
facing for example
let's say he's playing the defense and
we don't know he put his shut up to
contest shall put his arm up to contest
the shot so this would all be like very
useful data to have but but right now
it's we only have the coordinates thank
you
thank you I find it really fascinating
what you do with data so thank you very
much my question is when you're
processing all of these you probably
find yourself in front of thousands of
rows of data
how can you share some insider of how
you decide which data is useful and can
be actionable and which data is just
random
it's a real good question so a lot of it
depends on on maybe time of the year
which which game we're gonna play soon
whether we are developing some long-term
projects then we can do some more
research things through the research
oriented things during the season we'll
focus more on how our team is performing
evaluate our players in certain actions
how they are playing which lineups are
playing together well and then we'll
focus also on the opponents and try to
see what are the opponent's strengths
and weaknesses that we could use to to
to play better in the game yes
hi I have to question actually one is is
there any particular point of data that
you have noticed that it was like I
wasn't expecting that in the like is it
something on the data that was
surprising for you specifically that he
happens a lot when you watch the game
and and then I would see something and
like hey maybe I should check that so
then now I'll check it later and see if
it really confirms what I'm like seeing
it again
sometimes maybe I just see it a few
times in recent and in like a recent
game and then I'll think that this
happens often but then I'll check the
data and see that this actually does not
happen that much so some of these may be
things like that okay and the other one
you mentioned that one of the
interesting points will be to have a
register of what the player is actually
doing like where's watching and what's
trying to do is there any other thing
that you would like to track on games
[Music]
well besides the player's arms location
where he's facing I think they would to
give us a lot more complete picture I
think also whatever player jumped or not
because we have put for the basketball
we have the height of the ball but for
players we don't have whether he's he is
jumping how far he's jumping and you
know maybe how close is he coming to
blocking shot so we can't really see
that that data we can we can see how
much he effects the shot by how often
players make the shot against him but
having having a little more specifics on
how players playing it in it in a
defensive part of the game would
probably be very helpful
I first of all the presentation was
amazing and just the fact that you are
doing this in something that some people
can say it's completely out of the of
the completely different in areas it's
really really amazing I really loved the
whole speech book of a waste of money
well because of this that you use data
to to prove the game so that's really
really amazing
my question was regarding you say for
example you don't have you don't really
have the information like where is the
player facing and when he's doing a shot
or when it's a receiving a pass or
something and you say it's something
about watching the videos after have you
or is it a in thoughts of doing some
probably computer vision pipeline that
does this automatically and there's a
there's a package called open pose and
it can actually detect people in general
and and their body parts and their arms
legs and where where they are facing and
way to hold their arms so so there we
could look into extracting this
information from from the video but then
we only have like broadcast video so you
sometimes the player is and you know
outside of the screen of the the
broadcast a lot of times the broadcast
is facing on you know a coach or
something
and while the play is still happening so
you would lose a lot of information some
of it could be I guess inferred based on
where the players are and how they're
moving but it's a very complex problem
regarding that help probably this is
more personal but how do you feel that
the not the thing the sixty six hours
are ready to to the to the ideas that
you peach of using the data there are
really as
of these or or have you have you faced
really really difficult ones so to speak
to say no you can't you really can't do
that so I think we are very lucky at the
sixers our organization is very
receptive of the data and and I you know
our owners come from a financial field
so they used to looking at the data
making decisions based on data and they
invested a lot into our our data team I
research a research team so we have 10
people in our in our research team which
is the most of all the NBA teams and our
our coaches are also very receptive of
the data insights they like to they like
to make decisions that are based on the
objective data so they you know they'll
come to us with questions and and ask us
which which things are more effective
which you know defense type is better
against certain players and things like
that a very receptive of the data
analysis thank you very interesting talk
thank you
so my question is basically it's it's
actually a follow-up question so after
you get that data so you said there are
like 25 frames per second so and and
then and once we get those images then
we need to find out if if in those
images there was a drivel if it was a
pass so this labeling of images it
happens so you get labeled data or after
you get those images there is a food
label data on your site so sort of the
data that we get is already processed
from the video so we get we actually get
the COI tenets of the players already
processed from from the the cameras that
are indie arena and we also get markings
on top of that so the shots
passes it's all already provided by the
company thank you
yeah first of all thank you for your
talk it was really interesting my
question is regarding to the tracking
during the matches you mentioned you
don't get the results until one hour
after the matches
so does that video processing involves
any manual steps it's all done through
computer vision or or is some human
interaction they are for tagging what's
happening on matches thank you
well the company that that provides us
the data they already give us processed
data previously in in the last two years
they haven't been doing any human
tagging previously sometimes would there
was a person standing next to a computer
and and you know window would pop up and
ask hey is this player you know just to
confirm which player that is okay
sometimes maybe the number of teachers
on the players jersey was not readable
so so it required a little bit of
tagging but right now it's it's all
automatically processed
Julio Brenda hi I
I loved your talk have you know about
nothing basketball question I wouldn t I
would like to is that do you know about
song the you knows about some method so
model that you are developing and I
spotted analytics that have been
applying and all feel like business or
defense I would say a lot of the methods
that we use like from machine learning
from maybe clustering maybe regression
are pretty similar to what's what's used
in other in other fields so I think the
methods apply to to Baskerville it's
just like the way we interpret it it's
it's gonna change a bit based on context
hi thank you for the for the talk it two
short questions one how open is the
world of basketball analytics today the
breakthroughs get publish or are they
kept secret as a tool to take advantage
over your teams and if you can ensure
that which tools are you using from the
from the other side ecosystems that we
we can know so because the way you know
basketball is and ROI MBA is it's it's a
very competitive business you know
whoever wins the most games is you know
gonna have the most revenue
well mostly so we are very actually
secretive about how we evaluate players
how we evaluate teams if you think about
it the reason to do that is let's say we
want to trade with another team and we
we have certain model about a player and
we value this player maybe maybe more
than the other team does so the other
team will easily let go of this player
and we won't have to give them as much
as we value this player for example so I
think there's that there's a lot of
competitiveness there and we wouldn't
want went to other teams to know how we
evaluate players because then they would
know how much we value them and they
could ask for a higher price from the
technology standpoint we are in
developing our own codes and processing
and models in-house so mostly we just
write everything in Python we have our
database on the Amazon services and then
yes so most of the things we
[Music]
you